okay welcome welcome to the functional
programming toolkit this is a talk for
kind of beginner to intermediate people
interested in functional programming and
you've done a little bit but there's a
lot of things you don't understand like
monads for example or functors and all
this jargon so the point of this talk is
really to go through that jargon and
hopefully explain it to you in a way
that sort of demystifies it so it's
useful if you've done a little bit of
functional programming before but even
if you haven't I think you'll probably
be able to understand what I'm talking
about because I use lots of little
pictures so my name is Scott volution
and I have a website F sharp for fun and
profit the code examples in this talk
will be in F sharp but it's not not a
lot of code in this token so don't worry
about if you don't understand the code
so the main questions start with is why
do functional programmers use so many
strange words and it comes across as
very scary to most people there's words
like functor cat morphism applicative
carrying monoid and monad the most scary
word of all and I think the problem is
these words kind of sound scary but
they're not actually scary concepts if
you understood what they were I mean you
might be like Homer here and think I
can't possibly understand any of this
stuff it's way too complicated but it's
not I don't think it's scary I think
it's unfamiliar so if you knew what the
words meant or at least would
demystified a bit then you might be like
Homer here and you might say okay you
mapable if I call it a map up I could
understand that or a collapsible or an
aggregator for whatever the word is it
doesn't really matter what the words are
but these words don't sound as scary as
the sort of mathematical words so that's
really the goal of this talk is to
demystify you may not know what they
mean they still be unfamiliar but it's
they're not scary you know what's really
scary is object-oriented programming and
just because you're used to it you don't
think is scary but if I'm a brand-new
object-oriented program there's all
these words like polymorphism in the
hair
and generics and co-variants and solid
and solid is five other things and
there's IOC and di and ABC interview you
know you just don't realize how scary it
is if you are inexperienced there were
person so don't ever say that functional
programming is a scale words because oh
it's just as bad its jargon like we just
used to used to it
okay so there's four particular words
that I want to talk about in this talk
and like I say these are mathematical
words and you might think well this is
kind of an academic abstract theoretical
kind of thing but it actually turns out
these are very useful tools and again if
you demystified it hopefully you'll see
by the end of this talk they are
actually useful tools so there's
something called what I call the
functional toolbox and it's the
analogous with a a real toolbox and a
second in a real toolbox you have all
these different tools that you know and
each tool does one particular thing well
and you know if you're an experienced
person you know which tool to use for
which thing and a functional programmer
has a bunch of tools to you know map
return bind whatever all these tools
have names and if you're an experienced
person you know you know which tool to
use in which situation and basically
it's about eleven kind of important
tools you need to know about as maybe
you know ten other ones which are not
quite as important but if you know these
how to use these eleven tools you can
pretty much do everything in front of
the programming so this is a
problem-solving tool box it's not an
academic tool boxes for really getting a
hands dirty so what are the kinds of
problems that functional programs need
to solve well the first problem they
need to solve is composition because
everything in functional programming is
composition is the fundamental principle
and I'll talk about in a second how do
you combine things how do you aggregate
things that's a common problem in both
oh and functional how do you iterate
through things how do you work with
effects now this is a kind of more
functional programming thing they like a
plugin let's talk about effects all the
time and what do we mean by effects and
I'll explain what I mean by effects but
these effects are kind of tricky to work
with sometimes and so you have to mix
things which you're effects
non effects where you might need to
chain them or you need to work in
parallel
there's all different things you need to
work with when you have effects and
there's a bunch of tools just without
superposition so these are the kind of
words that you'll see a lot composition
uses to compose key words iteration
isn't generally called fold in
functional people combine and reduce
Mack and return sign which is also
called flat map apply and zip sequence
reverse these are the kinds of names of
functions or names of the tools that you
use a lot if you're doing functional
programming and of course if you enter
the jargon these things have actually
names so combination is generally called
amyloid when you work with different
kinds of effects that's you use a
functor if you want to chain effects as
a monad if you want to work in parallel
as an applicative so don't worry about
this I'm going to explain hopefully by
the end of talk all these things
hopefully they make sense and even if
they don't make sense I lived a little
bit less mysterious that's the whole
point so this talk is good it's going to
be one of those things like those
tourist buses where you go around the
city and you'd like stop for one minute
in each famous place you don't really
get a chance to look around but at least
you actually see the sights so that's
what this is as a whirlwind tour of the
sites you can't possibly understand
everything you know in one talk but
hopefully if you demystify and you go
away you know you can say oh I can and I
can at least not be scared I can go in
and learn more about it later on when I
get a chance so start with some
principles of statically typed
functional programming for people who
are newbies the first thing is the
functions of things and like luckily as
little well we attract analogy and the
composition is used everywhere so
there's no inheritance there's nothing
else's everything is composition and if
you know how to use Lego you know how to
do composition because this is exactly
the same so let's look at functions as
things so a function is a little thing I
like to use the railway track analogy in
this little tunnel tunnel transformation
something goes in if something comes out
in this case an apple go
and it turns into banana so this is a we
call this an apple - banana faction Maya
trot it transform samples into bananas
and the thing about functions is they
are standalone things they're not
attached to any class because they're
things they can be used just like you
might use an integer or a string or
something you can pass them around as
parameters you can put them in lists you
know you can do all sorts of things
because they're just things just like
everything else and this standalone
thing is really really important because
stand alone is another word for reusable
if it's on its own it can be reused in
any context if it's part of a class it's
really hard to sort of extract it from
that class and we use it in a different
context but all the functions in front
of the program they are standalone
functions so here's an example of a
function has a normal input but it has
an output which is a function here's an
example of a function that has a
function as an input and a normal outlet
here's a function with a normal input
and a normal output but it's got this
extra function which can be either sort
of parameterizing it and this would be
called the strategy pattern in our so
this is that's it that's really
everything you need to know about on to
the programming right there if you
understand that you understand
everything you can see it can get really
complex it's a very simple foundation
but you can have functions that return
other functions that generate other
functions which uses premises other
function it can get very complicated but
the fundamental principles are basically
just what I said in the last few minutes
and most the tools in the functional
toolbox that I'm going to be talking
about it our function transformers they
take functions in and they spit other
functions on so having functions come in
and functions come out that's a really
really common thing in functional
programming so the next principle which
is really important is composition so
I'm gonna talk about Lego for a second
because everyone understands how Lego
works hopefully and Lego actually has a
sort of philosophy right which is that
everything is designed to be connected
to everything else right you don't have
LEGO pieces which don't fit to other
LEGO pieces and if you connect your LEGO
pieces together you get another piece
which can still be connected to other
pieces right you never have you never
run into a wall where Owen
at any more LEGO pieces cuz I've run out
of dots or something you know and
they're reusable so here's some Lego
every single piece in Lego has little
dots so they're designed to be connected
and when you start assembling them you
know you don't you can just keep adding
and adding pieces you know they're
designed to be that way that you never
sort of hit a boundary you can add two
pieces and that makes another piece you
having more pieces you don't need a
special adapter you don't say well this
piece won't fit with this piece because
then I need a special sort of adapter
pattern to make two bits of Lego fit no
you don't have an adapter pattern in
Lego right they just literally connect
straight together and you can keep
adding and adding and adding and you can
make really really big things out of
Lego add all the small pieces and here's
the reusability thing right you can you
can make something and then you can
disassemble it and make something else
the pieces themselves do not have any
strings attached to literally they don't
have any strings attached if they had
strings attached they'll get tangled up
the springs will get tangled up and this
is one of the goals of functional
programming is that all the functions
that you built don't have any strings
attached
and because of that reusable they're not
attached to a particular context they're
not you don't have to kind of extract
them in order to reuse and they
literally are designed to be reusable
from the very beginning so you can make
really big things from small things in
Lego that's what I'd like to call the
power of composition now let's look at
the functional programming philosophy
which is very similar to the lego
philosophy and this is by the rent
automatic statically typed functional
programming dynamic type generic
function program is similar that there's
a little bit of difference so in front
of program you try to design functions
that do one thing well the solid
principles applied to functional
programming too but the functions can be
reused so you design your functions to
be reusable and you design them to work
together and you expect the output error
function might be the input to some
other function
you know you design them so that you
might be working with pieces that you
don't even know about yet and by the way
if you're familiar with the UNIX
philosophy this is exactly the same
the eunuchs yeah you know utility
philosophy wait and in fact Li type
functioning functional programming we
use the types to ensure that the inputs
match the outputs we make sure that you
can't accidentally put the wrong kind of
thing together so this is the functional
tool designing things that do one thing
we'll the toolkit is a very generic set
of functions that you use you know as
you're kind of building books so let's
look at function composition here's an
apple - banana function and here's a
banana - cherry function and how do you
glue them together how do you compose
them how do you make how do you connect
them well it's really obvious if they're
well we track you just literally stick
the two pieces together and you get any
function and what's cool about this is
you can't tell that this was built from
smaller functions right so you now have
another function that you can then use
to build bigger function and so on and
so forth and also what's cool is the
banana has disappeared where did the
banana go
you know you've now got some data hiding
you've got some abstraction the fact
that the thing was built from small
pieces which use something the bigger
function can hide all that so you you
know you've got this kind of nice API
and you can build really big things just
using functions without any classes of
objects sort of thing
so if you think about a web a website a
website is a function there's an HTTP
request comes in and it spits out an HD
hears once the whole thing as a giant
function it's with an input and output
and when you do a function functional
design inside your your main web
function you have all these little
little functions that do all that it'll
look and they're all connect together by
pipes
you don't need classes you can even
seriously build all right certificate
applications using purely functions and
if you want to call these microservices
be my guest
though micro-services are very similar
that's the non example of a parallel
composition so I have a whole talk on
this if you're interested on my website
all right so let's look at number one
tool number one tool is mano eights
okay or tool number one that's not not
the number one tool is the first tool
that I'm gonna be talking and there's
gonna be some mathematics here so I hope
this won't put you off okay if you if
you're scared of mathematics then let's
see so this is the first piece of
mathematics and this is the second piece
of mathematics and this is the third
piece of mathematics so this is all the
mathematics that we'll use so if you can
understand this you were like so what's
interesting is that mathematicians a
little bit like programmers and they
always like to make things
abstract they're always looking for
patterns so a mathematician would look
at this and say mom well just
interesting I can see if I can see some
patterns here and let's look at this can
we've got some things and we've got some
way of combining them and the result is
another of the same kind of thing you
add two integers you get another integer
back I wonder if that works or anything
else oh yeah it works or multiplication
too if I add if I multiply two things
I'd get another thing back another
integers back what else does it work for
well it works with strings if I have two
strings and I can catenate them I get
another string back and if I have two
lists and I can count Nathan I get
another list back so this is actually
quite a common pattern happens all over
the place okay what's interesting about
this pan is because when you add two
things together in this case you have to
introduce you get another integer you
can keep going so I can add 3 to that
and that gives me back another integer
right and so I can add 4 to that so I
can keep adding and adding and adding
just like the Lego so the Lego analogy
is quite good so what we have we start
off with a pairwise operation like
addition or multiplication or you know
adding these things together and we now
have an operation that works on lists we
can actually extend it infinitely adding
more more things without ever running
out no way what about the next one if
you know this is 1 plus 2 Plus 3 is the
same as 1 plus 2 plus 3 ok what that
means is that the order of combining the
things doesn't matter if you combine 2
plus 3 first or you can find 1 plus 2
first
the difference so you could do one plus
two and then you could add three and
then you get at four or you could do one
plus 2 here and the fridge was full here
and then add them later on
it really doesn't made it matter which
way you do it you always get the same
answer so that's good now it's not
always true like subtraction it doesn't
work with the order does matter for
subtraction subtraction doesn't fit this
pattern okay what about this zero thing
okay this is what is this zero mean so a
mathematician will say well this is very
interesting we have this very special
kind of thing that when you use it to
combine you know you can bind it with
this other thing you always get back the
original thing like the zero leaves that
alone it kind of doesn't do anything
it's a kind of a null pattern and it
turns out that zero is quite a common
thing so when you have multiplication
there's a special thing that when you
multiply you get the same thing back and
that would be the number one and if you
have strings there's a special thing
that when you add it to any other string
you get the same string back and that's
the empty string and so on and so forth
the empty list there's a zero conceptual
zero for all these kinds of things it's
very very common right so here's here's
the pattern that we've recognized we've
got a bunch of things we've got some way
of combining them two at a time and
that's the first rule we have is the
closure rule that when you combine them
you get another thing of the same type
and the second rule is associativity
which is when you combine them more than
one thing it doesn't really matter which
order you combine them in and the third
thing is there's a zero or an identity
element that when you combine it with
the thing you get the same thing back so
it like it doesn't do anything so these
are kind of you know these patterns are
pretty kind of obvious patterns if you
start thinking about it and the
mathematicians have a word for this
thing they call that a mono eight so
here's the mathematical jargon for
something which if you just look at it
from pattern analysis it's like yes it's
kind of quite a common pattern that I
read recognize so let's stop with the
jargon Homer says no more jargon don't
talk about monoids why is why is doing
kind of analyzing these patents why is
it useful like what how is it you as a
programmer well if you think about the
the closure will affect
you can combine two things and get
another thing that means that all powers
operations can be converted into things
that work on lists parents abuse start
with a pair and yet out of the list and
this is normally called reduce so if you
have 1 + 2 + 3 + 4 you have the plus
pair eyes operation and you can take a
list of integers 1 2 3 4 and reduce it
using + so the reduce operation all it
does is basically take the list of items
and stick that pairwise operation in
between every single one if you have a
multiplication that reduces a very
common practice one of the things enough
on some tools if you have a
multiplication that's the pairwise
operation we can then take a list of
numbers and we can reduce it using
multiplication alright and we can take a
list of strings do the same thing rather
than adding them up pairwise we can
collapse the entire list of strings into
a single string using the string
concatenation operator and so on so
forth for lists so this is a really
really common pattern now the
associativity the benefit of
associativity there's also some things
divide and conquer a parallelization
incremental accumulation I'll talk about
parallelization right now so
parallelization means that you can take
a bunch of stuff and you can spread it
out over multiple CPUs on one of my
machines or whatever so let's say we
have to add up 1 & 2 3 & 4 we could
paralyze it and say we'll do 1 + 2 on
this machine and we'll do 3 + 4 this
machine and then we'll take the results
or add them together
no ously you wouldn't do that with 4
numbers it's ridiculous but if you have
a million or 10 million things to do and
these are this pairwise operation is
quite complicated then this is great so
if you have a monoid you can instantly
parallelize it now
it turns out we don't normally most of
us don't have to worry about
parallelization but another really
useful thing is incremental accumulation
which is much more common so let's say
the EO boss asks you to add up 1 + 2 3
because your boss your boss is no good
at
and she's okay and then the next day
your boss says actually I've changed my
mind can you add up one plus two plus D
that's for today and then you say well I
have to start all over again you know I
just had it and now I have to go all the
way back to the beginning in that one
and two and four you know you don't of
course you can keep the number that you
calculated yesterday and just add 4 to
it you don't have to add the whole thing
up from the very beginning because of
this associativity I've already
calculated 1 + 2 + 3 which is 6 and all
I have to do add 4 to it so I don't have
to start from scratch
I can incrementally accumulate so every
time you have a monoid you can
incrementally in Hulme late data and
finally we have all these issues we run
into how do I reduce when the list is
empty how do I do a divide and conquer
when one of the steps is empty how do I
do incremental accumulation when I don't
have any starting data and that's what
the identity element is really good for
it's the initial value for empty data or
missing data so you have these fake
things and you can anything once you see
this pattern you start seeing it
everywhere and you can have a missing 0
you can have patterns where there's no
zero and the mathematicians got that a
semigroup
which is even more obscure so let's look
at a real example let's say we have to
do some aggregation say we have a bunch
of order lines and we have to add them
up and find out the total now we could
write a loop and write a specialized
piece of code dried them up the problem
with that again is if I've again with
three or four things it's not fun but if
I have a million things then tomorrow I
have a million the first thing I have to
start I have to run the whole loop all
over again you know so let's use the
monoid idea because that gives us best
of bullet over all possibilities so
rather than trying to write a loop what
I'm going to do is say well you know
integers are mono AIDS floats amides any
combination of a mind as another money
so all the line is a moment and all I
have to do is write a pairwise combiner
where I just add the two pieces and
return the new thing so I have a pair
wires combiner which is normally pretty
straightforward to write and then once
I've got the pairwise combiner
I can run it on the entire list just
reduce the entire list using the
pairwise combiner so there you go that's
there's really there's a pattern it
would be useful not to say if I have
another order line come in tomorrow I
don't have to recount the entire total
them swatch I can just add this extra
one by using the incremental
accumulation principle profit now a lot
of situations you don't have mono s so
for example I have a bunch of customers
and I want to find out how you know at
let's say I keep track of how many times
they visit my website how much money
they spend or whatever I'd like to add
all that stuff up but I can't because
customers are not mano eights however I
could create a special kind of class or
a structure called customer statistics
which is just integers and stuff and
that would be a mono because it's all
kind of numbers so what they typically
do is you take something which isn't a
ma night and you turn it into something
which is a mano it's and once you've got
it as a monoid you can then reduce it
down so good turning something which
isn't in a model it in term honor that's
Mac and then clapping the whole thing
down into a single values reduce and
you've probably heard of MapReduce but
MapReduce out with them so that's why
it's called MapReduce it's something to
do its moist
so here is a nice treat I saw a long
long time ago how'd it make me a
sandwich so how do you 'pizza is it just
you know it does parallel computation
and you start off with let's say you
start off with some bread and some
lettuce and whatever and onion or
whatever you can't just mush them
together and make a sandwich right
they're not they're not composable
they're not mono it's but if I slice the
loaf and I slice the onion I slice the
lettuce the slices can be composed into
sandwiches so you know you can then
reduce the the slices interest
intercessor session of sandwiches so
this is mapping followed by reduce as a
way of you know making sandwiches so
it's kind of fun right here's the
problem with monoids is once you
recognize this pattern you start seeing
in everywhere for example if you do
devops or something and you need to keep
track of
six there's a little rule saying use
counters rather than rates and if you
say if you're into mono age you say just
make sure you metrics the moloids
because you can do incremental updates
and you can handle missing data
Renaissance art and in fact many many
design patterns are actually mono is
behind the scenes Marc seaman just wrote
a blog post the other day about this
things like the composite pattern is a
mono it the null object hand is a mono
composing commands together to make a
new command is a mono it and if you're
into DVD in the DVD book it talks about
closure of operations
that's the mod so you really start you
know it really kind of wounds you
actually now you say well why use the
word monoid there's a jargon your word
but just like any piece of jargon once
you know what it means it's a shortcut
to explaining something quite
complicated so if I say to somebody else
and I say this is a monoid and they know
what that means assuming they know what
that means they will instantly know that
they can paralyze it but they can do
incremental stuff that it has a zero
element you know all these kinds of
things so it's a it's a great shortcut
for explaining you know a company and
they also know watch patterns to use how
to work with them straightaway what
about a functional composition is that a
monoid so here's an app you know whose
are two functions and we compose them
together and we make this Apple to carry
function it's not the same kind of thing
the Apple the you know one thing is an
apple - banana function the other is an
apple - cherry function so composing
functions there is not really a male -
unfortunately but if we have functions
that turn apples into apples and we
combine them we get another function
which turns apples and apples and that
is a monoid because it's exactly the
input functions and the output function
is the same kind of thing so if you're
working with functions that turn
integers into integers or strings into
strings that those kinds of things you
can actually do them incrementally you
can do them you know whatever all that
kind of stuff because they're wrong
weights right so that's everything you
know about mermaids a set of values a
combining function and it has also such
words
even if this is what I say so pattern
you couldn't recognize because the
actual word that he used with an abiding
function could be anything
so for Strings or lists it's it's not
the golfing cat for an integer Zitz
called plus in Haskell is the angle
bracket sometimes and sometimes you see
a platino you're plus all sorts of weird
symbols and things but it's the same
concepts everywhere and this combination
the combiner has to be closed
associative and zero so here you can use
it for reducing a list you can use it to
do parallel computation you can use it
for doing incremental calculations all
this stuff so there you go that's a
monoid
so that's tool number one hopefully my
nodes are not quite as scary now
all right as demystified a little bit I
hope now we're going to go even more
scarier but and talk about effects so
what is an effect functional programmers
talk about effects all the time so
effect is really just a generic type
like a list a list of something or it
could be a type with some extra data in
it like an option type or a result type
it could be a type that changes the
state of the world like in a sink or it
interacts with the world you know tars
random number generators or it could
carry state around like a state type of
cars or type it can be all sorts of
state it's actually kind of vague one
effect is it really could be all sorts
of stuff it's basically you know really
it's just a generic type person you know
generic type is is is a normal type with
some extra stuff right so I'm going to
focus on three types in this talk to use
them as examples list an option and a
sink so hopefully everyone knows what
list is the option type if you're using
Java this no not there's an optional
stuff built in hopefully is most people
are familiar with the optional type of
some kind and the async type is it you
can think of it's like the task type
it's kind of similar f-sharp uses a sink
and then C shop uses tasks so this whole
thing of effects there's like normal
world and effects world okay so in
normal world you have strings and you
have integers and you have billions
anyhow functions the turn strings in the
instance of strings you have function of
the turn into bills so this is like your
normal world of the normal everyday
objects now what's interesting is for
every kind of effect type like options
unless normally there's a parallel world
it's like a mirror world and everything
in this world is options for example so
instead of having strings you have
optional strings instead of into your
options and optional books and every
function that turns an instant of string
in optional world that function turns
optional innocent optional strings or it
turns optional in sins are optional
bills all right so it's like a parallel
universe and same thing with lists
worlds in list worlds everything is
lists of things there's a list of
strings and lists events and this the
billions and all the functions turn
lists into lists you know so this is
mindful analogy for these worlds and
it's going to be quite an important
concept we're going to be talking about
these worlds quite a lot and async is
another world everything you can see how
it's going right you can see the pattern
here and so there's this called generic
effect no matter what effect it is
there's some sort of e I'm going to call
Eve a generic effect and there's generic
effect types and a generic effect
functions okay so that's my effects
world so that's the that's everything
you need to know about effects just
remember every time you hear someone
talk about effects you can probably
replace it with option or list or a sink
or whatever so here's here's our first
problem is how do we work with these
effects we need to do stuff in the
effects world sometimes and how do we do
that and I'll give you a some concrete
examples so let's say here's the world
of normal values and here's the world of
options and sometimes we have a function
that takes us from the world from the
normal world into optional world and
then we need to work with the data in
the option so we then basically extract
that data and we do something with it
and then somehow it goes back up into
optional world again and then we extract
the data again and it goes back into
optional world this back and forth
between worlds is a really common
pattern
it's actually really bad and so like
don't do this all right functional
progress which would call this a kind of
design smell or code smell so like well
you know how could how do you solve that
right what you really want to do is when
you go into the effects world whatever
it is you want to stay there you want us
to keep working up there and only come
down at the very end if you have to I
mean a good example in c-sharp is the
task or the async/await
once you've made something async or you
turn into your basically stuff you let
you have to everything else has to work
in that world in the async world or the
task world and you only ever come down
at the very top of your program you
don't you know it's bad bad practice to
like a wait for a task to finish and
then start another task than to wait for
the side what you want to do is lift
everything up into this async world and
work up there and then at the very end
of your program which is you all can
fall or whatever it is that's where you
actually deal with the async or the task
so that's the right way to do so let's
say we have an ad for to function very
important function and if we went on a
normal thing like 1 we get the answer 43
if we were not on another thing which is
an option world like someone it doesn't
work it only works on normal things
doesn't work on options so this ad 42
function is useless as that by the way
it's dance so we say ok well let's write
our own custom ad 42 - option function
so we say well if the option is
something if it's about it then we're
gonna you know run the ad 42 and then we
have to wrap it back up into option
world again and if it was never
something then we're done we don't have
to do anything so we're we're unwrapping
it we're doing the thing that we need to
do and then wrapping a break up again
and that's like I say that's a bad way
to do it you're going down you're doing
something you come back up this is an
antique man so what you instead you want
to do is you want to somehow be able to
work with this ad 42 function up in the
effects world in the optional world so
we want to stay up there so how do we
how do we how do we make an ad 42
function up there without having to
the only special thermal every single
time and that's what mapped us so this
map is a there's a function transformer
that moves functions from one world to
another Wells so if we have a function
down here that turns T's into use if we
do option map it turns options of cheese
into options of use that's what option
that does so in our code instead of you
know with our normal function we can say
option map around 42 and that gives us
our and 42 to option so now we have a
the add 42 now works in the world of
options and we can run it straight away
so we now have a function in the option
where we didn't have to write any
special code to wrap it and unwrap it
again it just happens for free and
typically we don't actually write a
special we don't give it a special name
we digitally inline it like this the
option out of this and we can apply it
to the other thing same thing with this
world let's say we want to add 42 to
each integer each item in the list so
you know for each item in the list we
had 42 and then we put it back in the
list again and return the new list say
but we're doing this thing when you're
doing an iteration you're basically
unwrapping things out of the list you're
pulling out each element out one at a
time applying the thing and then putting
them back in a list again so again this
has been a dependent you don't want to
come down do the thing and go back up
don't do that again we can instead we
use lists map so it takes a normal
function down a normal world you run
list map and it gives you a function up
in list world so if I wanted to find the
add 42 to each function all I have to
say is list map of the add 42 function
now I have a function that works on this
I didn't have to write any special code
so that's kind of cool so you can see
that this map is really really useful
and people say well I can always write
my own loops why is this any easier than
writing my own loops and the answer is
that again if you if once you know what
this map does first of all it's easy for
you to use because you don't have to
write any code secondly it's also easier
for someone else to understand assuming
they understand
how how it works they can look at your
code and they know exactly what's going
on sometimes if you look at a
complicated loop you're trying to figure
out what's actually going on in this
loop you know because it's not the loop
logic kind of gets in the way of the
actual thing that you're trying to do if
you use things like this map the loop
logic it's kind of hidden so you can
really focus on what's actually being
transformed what's actually going in
this case it's really obvious that we're
adding 42 to each item now if I had a
head of loop and there was like 42 in
there it would take me some time to
figure it out so I actually think this
is better once you understand what this
map does it's actually easier and of
course async same thing we have a normal
function and we can map it into the
world at resync and that way we can kind
of chain async function together so most
generic types have a map there's no
single zone you use them and if you are
your own generic type that you're going
to put out in a library make your own
map and then everyone else can use it
and of course now we have the jargon
version of Mac so the jargon version is
it's a funk guitar so a function is an
effect type which again is option nor a
single list or one or whatever it is
plus some sort of map function that
works with it there's specifically
designed so you know the definition the
implementation of map for options is
different from the implementation of map
for lists which is different from the
implementation of map for tasks or you
think whatever but the concept is the
same so I can use in a list map or
whatever once I know that this thing is
this I know exactly how to use it the
map function has all sorts of different
names sometimes it's called selects
sometimes called lifts sometimes it's
called f map so it needs to have a
sensible implementation it turns out
there's a bunch of things called a
functor laws which is really just a
fancy name for some rules that
implementations should have to make sure
that they work sensibly like you thought
you shouldn't do them something too
stupid and the function laws are just
basically a way of making sure that your
implementation makes sense so that's
number two what about number three well
this is a really simple one this is just
sometimes you know we just talked about
moving functions from one world to
another let's talk about moving
individual values like integers or
strings and that's called the turn so
here a word of normal values and we want
to make it an optional int we just use
return right here it is and here's a
normal value and we make it an optional
int or lacking something similarly with
lists if we are a single integer and we
want to make a list out of it we use
lists return and that makes a list
events so here you have 42 and we make a
list out of it you know just in this
case it's really easy it's just tonight
single item in our lists so again it's
not normally called return I mean the
actual way of making these things that
the name is all sorts of it's all
different in different environment the
concept is you're just moving thing from
one world to another value normal world
value in this world so you bear with me
you probably thinking all these things
are they actually you know useful and at
the very end of the talk I'm actually
going to show you how to assemble all in
a real piece of code using all the
different tools together and you so just
think about how you know how these tools
can work together to build a complex
program now this is the most important
tool probably in the function problems
which is bind and it's it's is used for
world crossing functions I think what
they it's a world crossing function okay
I know introducing all these kind of
concepts but they're not they're not
some particularly difficult to
understand I don't think it's just
something different that you're not used
to if you you know on a functional
program so here's a function called
range and you give it a maximum number
and it will give you a list of all the
numbers up to that number so if you give
it a you know the maximum of 100 it give
you all the numbers from 1 to 100 okay
pretty straightforward now if you look
at the what it does you pass in an int
and you get back a list events right so
you have a value in normal world and the
output is a value
list the world this is really really
common so if you think about it like
this you start off with an int down here
and you end up with the list of ends up
here I mean this is range
now here's another more complicated
example let's say you're getting a
customer from a database are you passing
the customer ID if the customer is found
then you can say yeah I found some
customer data and I'm going to give it
back to you if I didn't find the
customer I say okay I won't give you
back anything and again if you look at
the inputs and outputs for the function
it says will you give me a customer ID
which is a normal thing and I'll give
you an optional piece of customer data
so the the input is in normal world but
the output is an option world so again
this is a world crossing function it
starts down at the bottom and ends up at
the top these functions are really
really common in functional programming
so the cases that get customer function
so this is like really really really
really common problem and how do you
change these things together so here's
some code it's just it's kind of silly
in this example you have you do
something and you get back an X and
let's say that do something is a world
crossing function it returns an option
say well I can't really do anything with
the X unless I know whether it's valid
or not so I have to say is it something
if it's something let me go on and then
I do something with that and that maybe
that gives me another something and I
have to say I have to check that as well
and maybe then only when it's valid can
I do the next thing and I have to check
that as well and only when it's rylynn
can I get the next thing and so on now
you could replace this with null
checking you probably seen the same kind
of code if it's not now do the next
thing if that's not no I'll do the next
thing you know if that's not null do the
next thing so this is just the the
option version exactly the same code and
it's this horrible thing you get this
massive thing you've got all these
nested checks and they and they add up
they get if you get more more
indentation in your code and this is
typically called the pyramid of Doom
because you're you know as you if you
have like three checks it's already
pretty until you have 20 checks it's
gonna be you know it's just ridiculous
you wouldn't want this is just horrible
code nobody wants to code like this and
you see this all the time in other
situations let's say we're doing with
guitar
and we went a task and then when the
task is finished we get the rally that
gets output and we run the next task
with that and then when that task was
finished we do the next thing and when
that's finished we did the next thing
so whether these are tasks or promises
or futures whatever you wanna call them
you see this pattern a lot - and again
it's a pyramid of doom
you can have a world crossing function
you always have to check
you always have to kind of deconstruct
it you have these nested two callbacks
in this case and you end up with this
pyramid so this is ugly no matter what
it is so let's see if we can solve this
problem let's fix this there's a pattern
here that we can exploit you might see
if it's something do something if it's
something do something if it's something
do something this is the pan so let's
turn that intraductal helper function
okay we're going to say if it's
something do something and if it's not
then we do nothing that's the pattern so
what exactly we do we don't know what
we're going to do with that thing
so let's parameterize it we're going to
say we'll pass in a function parameter
and the function parameter will do what
we want to do we don't have to worry
about what it is exactly so we might a
piece a little a piece of code like this
if something do and if it's if the if
the input is optional then we run this
with a helper function and if it's not
though it's missing so this parameter
this function parameter is the things
that you want to do as the next step if
you valid so once we have this little
helper function we can rewrite our
original code to look like this do
something and if it's something then do
the next thing and if this if that one
isn't something then do the next thing
and in fact something do the next thing
and this what this little helper
function does is basically clean up all
that nested stuff we now have a nice
linear vertical-align thing there's no
indentation going on so this is a really
really nice way of tidying up your code
how I'm going to use the railway analogy
so with options you can sort of think of
there's an input and there's two kind of
two possible outputs there's either
something or it's nothing
and if it's something we want to do the
next thing in the chain and if it's
nothing we want to bypass right so if
you actually had little bits of railway
like if you're playing with Brio or
wouldn't wouldn't well we have some kind
how would you connect these things
together well you couldn't connect them
like that but you could connect them
like that so this is this is you know
this is very close to what we want but
if we can get something like this then
we've connected more together very
nicely so that's our goal now here's the
problem if we have one track functions
with one input and one output they're
easy to compose we just connect the
inputs and outputs if we have to track
functions with two inputs and two
outputs they're also easy to compose we
just want them up in the obvious way but
what we have is one track input and to
track output and those things cannot be
composed they just they don't fit
together properly so how can we combine
mismatched functions like this and the
answer is bind bind all things
functional programmers love the word
bind so here we are here's our problem
again we've got these kind of points
that don't compose if we had to track
functions they would compose those are
good so how do we get from before to
after okay well we have a function
adapter a function transformer and if
you think about the wooden railway track
you can actually get these kind of
little wooden adapter blocks that you
stick in you know so you know you put in
this in this adapter block you stick in
your your points function and it comes
down as a two track function and that's
at RSA it's a kind of function
transforming functions as input and
functions as output and the
implementation it's it's big SMO you
know it's actually a very simple
impression it's like literally four
lines of code it's more complicated to
explain and then to actually show the
code so here's the code an input comes
in and if it's something we do the next
function we do the thing that you pass
in and if it's nothing we don't know
anything so that's actually the entire
implementation of bind for these kinds
of points functions
so if we use it for training options
this is what it looks like before if we
use up a chain for doing you know we
write this in a bind helper function by
the way is exactly that little if
something do function that's exactly the
same so that if something do is actually
buying the same thing again it's got
this parameter that you pass in as the
next thing in the chain and then our
code then becomes linear so we're now
using bind as look as the word here so
no pyramids and it's linear and clean
and if we do the same thing with tasks
when a task completes we do the next
thing in the task and if it doesn't
complete whatever we don't do the next
thing same kind of pattern we write
little task bind insert okay so this is
the ugly version with the pyramids of
doom and we added a task bind which
again is no it's a different
implementation but it has the same
concept it's like chaining tasks
together when we get the result we want
to run a function on it okay there's a
little what is our parameterised next
function and then once we have something
like this we can then whoops we can then
connect all the the tasks together in a
linear way we can you know start a task
and then we can bind that to the next
task and we can bind that to the next
task of buying that to the next task so
this is the it's as I said my as a
general concept it's not just
specifically for options on this sort of
tarsus a concept you can apply to almost
anything to any kind of effect and let's
look at one more example which is error
handling so here's an example of a
function that doesn't narrow handling
you receive a request you validate
requests you might canonicalize the
email maybe make sure it makes make sure
it's a lower case you might update the
database you might send an email to the
customer or something who knows but this
is pretty you know it's only five lines
of code is pretty straightforward but
here's the problem
errors happen like what happens if the
request is not valid what happens if the
customer isn't found in the database
what happens if you get a database
exception what happens if the SMTP
server doesn't send email you know all
of a sudden you start off with a bunch
of simple code and also in your code
gets really complicated in this case
it's three times longer or twice as
twice as long as those
and this is you know if you've written
our handling code this you see this all
the time you start over something which
it starts off really simple and it gets
kind of cluttered and complicated and
messy and and you lose track of what the
important features are the important
stuff is is buried in all error handling
so let's look at the functional
equivalents we're going to define a
result type which basically is two
choices it's got a success case an okay
case and an error case or a failure case
and it's one of these points functions
again something comes in and it can
either come out as a success or come out
as a failure and then all our little
validation functions basically say in
this case if it's if the name is blank
as an error if the emails blank that's
an error if they otherwise it's fine and
you go through all the all your
functions in your workflow you do the
exactly same thing and you end up with a
bunch of points functions like this
validating might might not return an
error updating a database my oh my oh my
oh my not return there are sending an
email might be an error or whatever
again you have exactly the same
situation here before we have these
points functions and we want to connect
them together and there we go we're done
so that's the two-track model of error
handling otherwise known as a railway
order programming and I have a whole
talk on that if you're interested so
here's the here's the code before we
added error handling let's say we don't
do any Harry handle we just throw
exceptions right so we take the request
we validate it we do all the stuff it's
nice and clean but there's no error
handling right because maybe a one track
now if we add the error handling in
let's see how much more complicated it
makes it okay we're going to do a lot of
error handy now every single thing's
gonna be handled nicely so afterwards
this is what it looks like
alright it looks exactly the same now
I'm cheating a little bit because I'm
using this exactly the same names of the
functions but I could validate requests
where they were handling an archive
email with error handling your update DB
were there anything you could name the
function slightly differently but the
point is you still get this nice
workflow but behind the scenes in the
two tracks you're handling all the
errors really nicely this is a very nice
because it keeps the keeps the coke
clean right so binds and C is really
important the reason it's important as
it makes world crossing function is
composable so let's make now let's take
bind and just make it very generic to
any kind of effect they could ever think
of
it's because it's a pattern really this
is a conceptual way of thinking about
props we have these world crossing
functions which starts off in normal
worlds and it ends up in the world of
effects so this is a kind of a diagonal
function you're going diagonally from
one world to another and the problem
with these things is they're not
composable right now what bind does is
it turns it into something where the
entire function lives in the world of
effects so it's a horizontal function so
you've turned a diagonal function into a
horizontal function now these horizontal
functions are great because they're easy
to compose you can literally just glue
them together so let's look at example
of that so let's say you have a bunch of
diagonal functions like this right you
take like say you can't glue them
together they just don't work doesn't
work but if you use bind and you turn it
into a horizontal function like this and
bind again now we have a bunch of
horizontal functions and they can all be
glued together so this is why by just so
important it's a way of chaining
together diagonal functions and diagonal
functions are functions they happen all
the time whenever you whenever effects
happen every time you you know you you
work with the i/o whether you worth a
database whether you work with options
or errors or results or this whether
this happens a lot so that's why i buyed
are so nice that's the right way to do
it so back to some terminology again now
we know what a monad is so a monad is an
effect type of whatever kind you want to
call it like option or list or anything
from the same whatever it does really
doesn't matter what it is plus of a turn
function it turns normal values into the
things well that's trivial you do you
underst
they were and return is sometimes called
pure sometimes goal unit there's lots of
names right now here's the key thing
there's a bind function that converts
the diagonal function into a horizontal
function so this is you have these three
things and of course people are
inconsistent with the naming my
programmers always are some people call
it bind some people call it Mac Mac in
Haskell they don't even have a name for
it is just as funny symbol with two
angle brackets in c-sharp if you use
link select many is a bind operation and
you have to have sensible
implementations and those are the Monad
laws so when you hear something like the
Monad laws you know if you break the
Monad laws you're going to go to jail no
if you break the Monad laws it just
means that your your code doesn't work
the way people would expect because
you're not the implementation doesn't it
doesn't make any sense so that's what a
monad is a monad is there's these things
it's just that a type plus two functions
plus some rules you have to follow when
you implement it so hopefully it's not
so scary
maybe maybe monad a little little bit
demystified
okay so monads are so important because
you have these effect generating
functions you want to chain them in
series you need to use a monad now one
quick thing is mono is versus mono AIDS
and this sounds like the same words they
are efficiency they actually different
but there's a there is a connection
because there's another way of composing
these points functions you can compose
two points functions get back another
points function it's the same kind of
thing and there's there's a symbol for
that kind of thing angle bracket equals
angle bracket what's interesting is if
you combine these two things you get
back another thing at the same type does
that sound familiar so you can repeat it
repeatedly add things to them and it
also turns out that the order that you
can buy things doesn't matter so this
looks awfully familiar
and in fact if you do this this kind of
composition is in fact I'm already using
points functions right enough of that
one more thing and then we're talking
lives
so we have these effects like we have an
option of something and on that option
something will you combine them so get a
pair so let's say we have an optional 42
and an optional hello and we can find
them when we get a pair you know an
optional 42 and hello as a pair as a
tuple which is affecting what you expect
now if one of the things is nothing then
the overall result is nothing all right
that's also what you'd expect
now what about lists if we combine two
lists and we create a pair of item pair
of items from each lists how do you do
that well it turns out there's actually
two different ways one is the cross
product so if I have 1 2 3 and ABC I can
pair each one with every other one so
one at a and then one being on C and 2a
or 2b and 2c and so on so there's nine
possible answers the other alternative
is zip when you zip to this together you
just take them pairwise first one in the
first one 1a and 2 B and 3c so there's
two different ways of combining lists
the general term the combining things
like this is a picutre functor another
another kind of nasty word and optional
s an async electives pretty much
everything you're going to run into can
be treated as an objective so a package
functors that's a horrible name really
isn't it again it's one of these effect
types plus of a turn function plus some
way of combining these two effects into
one and it's got all again also sort of
names apply pair different slightly
different implementations exactly how it
works but the whole point is you're
basically combining things and again
there has to be sensible implementations
which it calls a functor applicator
functor laws and so on all right why is
this useful it sounds kind of
interesting but it's actually relevant
well here's a here's a really common
problem you want to validate field in
parallel let's say we have a customer
and they have to have you know the name
has to be 50 characters exactly or less
than 50 characters it can't reward the
email address has to be validated being
outside that you know it has to be
proper birthdate which is more than 19
less than the Hyundai whatever often you
have these validation rules so we
complete some validation functions just
like our points functions that we've
done before but when you chain them
together the problem is if there's an
error we get the first error and then
the rest of them are bypassed so we get
one error and all the other possible
errors we never even know about so you
know that's okay but it'd be nice if you
get all the errors at once right that
would be nice
so what you do is you say you start off
with a piece of JSON or a little you
know the DTO toy where nothing is about
it the string could be anything in the
email could be anything for each field
in this data structure you won the
little validation rule and you get back
some results and then you combine the
output to make a final sign that way you
get to keep all the errors at once
that's what we want to basically run
this stuff in parallel rather than in
series so how do we combine them that's
where the applicative comes in so we
have all these different values which
live in result world we have a result of
a name it might or might not be valid we
have a result of an email that might or
might not be valid and a birthday that
might or might not be valid how do we
combine them well we don't have to
combine them in the normal world if we
have a valid name and a valid email and
so on we just use the constructor to
combine them right we can we use the
constructor and we now get a van a
customer but this is working in normal
world
what's cool about applicatives is that
you can turn a function that works in
normal worlds into a function that works
in result world so you can take that
constructor function and kind of lift it
up into result worlds using the magic of
applicatives I'm not going to tell you
how to do it because it's kind of
confusing but the point is you can take
these individual things and make a
customer and this customer is in result
world and it's done in parallel so if
there's any errors all the errors are
combined so if you look at the code for
this
here's creating a valid customer in
result worlds we do you know is that
validate the one thing the other thing
we get the name or an area it's not
necessarily a valid name it could be a
name or an error right now that
constructor is the normal constructor
but we use these magic symbols here with
the angle brackets and we call it just
like with a different
just like we've called the normal
constructor but we use the magic symbols
instead of just a normal function call
and this is magic and the output means
that we get this error message here's
the magic symbols and not that explain
how they work but the cool thing is that
everything works just like you're
calling a normal function now notice
that we get a list of error messages how
do we combine the list of our messages
combining two lists to make another
lists we're using monoids so we're using
applicative nanoids
in this example alright let's review the
tools we've got combined which combines
two values we got reduce which reduces a
list we have map which lifts functions
up we have return which lifts individual
values up we have bind which turn this
diagonal functions into horizontal
functions we have apply which combines
things in parallel and there's other
words for that you might see lifts and
so on right let's look at an example I
think I'm running a little bit late I'll
just be another couple of minutes let's
use all the tools together so let's say
that you need to download at a URL into
a JSON file and then you need to parse
that jason interest for example a
customer dto and then you need to turn
that DTO intervallic customer and then
you need to store that customer in their
database okay now we all got these
different worlds going to be working
with when we download the JSON file we
start off with the URL in the normal
world as a string and we actually end up
in async world's an async world which is
on top of the result world so when you
download it it could be a valid piece of
JSON or it could be an error because the
server didn't was one and the whole
thing is async because it doesn't
response right away
so we've got an async of a result of a
piece of jason okay that's our first
function the next function we take that
piece of jason and we parse it when we
decode it into the customer DTO but that
might fail because the Jason's invalid
right okay so that's it could be an
error and then we take the customer DTO
and we take out the three fields and
each one of these might on my got a
valid and then we take those three
fields and we can make a customer and
then we take that customer in normal
world and we store it in a database
which again it might or might not still
properly and it might be asynchronous so
we have all these functions and how
we're going to compose them together
they're all diagonal functions all weird
shapes they're just not going to be
composed together none of the stuff
matches up but luckily we can use our
functional toolkit which we know how to
use so the first thing is we have these
parsing thing and then creating the
customer we just saw had to do that with
the applicatives so we can actually
replace that with a function that turns
the DTO
into a customer okay so we've got a DT
oh and a customer now where does the DTO
come from it comes from parsing the JSON
but when we parse the JSON we don't get
a DT oh we got a detail or possible
error so it's not compatible we have
these diagonal functions well how do we
do that we use bind okay we do bind on
these two functions and now we get some
horizontal functions which we can then
connect together we compose them
together into one function which now
takes Jason and turns it into a customer
and then here's the code for doing that
we have a JSON or error we bind the
first thing we bind the second thing so
they're literally the code is tiny
okay the problem with this is it's still
in result well we need to move it into a
sink worlds so we use Mac and now it
lives in async will and then that's last
one storing a customer is again it's a
diagonal function so we're going to use
bind on it again to turn it horizontal
right and now we have the first one goes
up to async worlds so Jason to customer
is now all in async worlds the customer
to storing a database is also an async
world so these are now all exactly the
same types we can glue them together and
make one single function that goes all
the way from one to the other
so there's an example of how you'd use
these tool that you use to this toolkit
so here's the code again but to download
install custom we start with ul we
download the file we take the process
thing we just defined and map it up and
then we use bind on the last one to wrap
it up so again just a few lines of codes
it really takes a lot longer to explain
everything than to actually write the
code you could write this code in mini R
- yeah so but we're using the same tools
I'm using different kinds of tools that
the concepts are the same all the way
through so just one thing to take away
even if you don't understand everything
which I don't think you cross that we
can the jargon
is jargon just like any kind of joking
but it's not that scary you know you can
it's just unfamiliar and hopefully you
can see one functional people go on
about monads all the time right now this
is a very generic toolkit they've got a
set of functions like Mack and bind that
work for anything it's a set of patterns
this is really the equivalent of the
pattern language just like used to
strategy pattern and factory pattern and
so on this is the kind of equivalent
pattern language for functional
programming so we use these consequences
over and over and we just sort of use
whole bunch of them just for this one is
example hopefully you can now see when
you see map and apply and bind use
you'll have some idea of what they're
for but like I say I wouldn't expect you
to understand them or it takes a while
to get used to them so there's the
functional programming toolkit I'm going
to post the slides up on my website if
you're interested in this I've got other
talks I've got a whole thing on design
patterns I've got a whole thing on
composition the whole thing under main
modeling I have a whole book on domain
modeling if you were into that follow me
on Twitter if you're interested and
otherwise thanks so much for coming
[Applause]
I feel free to ask me questions I'll be
around all day